hello guys magnesite welcome to the real
rejects Channel I'm Greg John Greg John
Greg John I'm John Greg John Wayne John
Wayne it's a terrible cowboy vengeance
this is my writing not Tyrone's is the
upcoming superhero crime drama series
the series I know in our teaser we
thought it was a movie starring Tyrone
Magnus as Derek chambers all right a
blue-collar worker who gets wound up in
the underground crime trafficking world
no well that's accurate of Tyrone's life
he's constantly paying to have services
in the crime trafficking world when he
watches a job the organization comes
after him to kill him the only problem
is they didn't bury him deep enough
they buried me nice
took away everything I ever cared for
nice good and he helped me out there's
only one problem for them though they
didn't bury me deep enough they sent an
army after me
three three the funny thing is I'm
bringing the war to them
damn boom
Tyrone Tyrone you my n-word dog I didn't
say it
we're friends I can at least say you're
my N word right I don't know you know I
know I mean I know it's not exact so
subscribers and I get upset remember you
saying that but this is about Tyrone and
if the Tyrone is gonna be cool with me
saying it I guess it's up to Tyrone let
me say the word all gets hard any seven
hot hears you say that to decide whether
or not they're okay with it looks pretty
cool I love like what's the word for
like noon or la setting like that ryan
le crime kind of vibe feel like ever
since drive or michael man fills people
have really been capitalizing off of
that and you definitely get that vibe
here he told me that he bang that chick
it was punching his hands like he banged
her in the sense that like he when she
you know they'd switched he he punched
her hands no i'm talking about that he
had sexual relations with her oh good
I'm glad that you just not trying to
respect her any rumors I'm not making
anything up he's not at all sure this is
just things that Tyrone and I had as a
personal conversation cuz that's what
kind of guy Greg is he's just an open
book I'm an open book
who doesn't lie about it a book that
will find you and ask to be written I
thought I wrote had a punch to that's
also true
yeah scenes I taught Tyrone how to punch
I taught him how to do a perfect push-up
I taught him how to light I seen that
one
yeah like put blue on the one side and
like a reddish purple on the other no I
do I do like the way they're shooting
this it's very colorful in it and it
harkens back to I don't want to I don't
want to just say this black exploitation
well no but there's like a 70s 80s you
know [ __ ] exploitation vibe I mean
there's there's probably some
blaxploitation elements in there it
seems a little exploitation you know it
seems like it's it's gonna relish in the
grits and the grunge
yeah which these kinds of stories yes
sure but you know like there's a really
creative color palette a thank you
they're clearly imagining those older
cinematography style and Tyron did a
great job on the delivery to them that
little speech he had mmm little
monologue there there's intense man yeah
I was intense I believed him and it
sounded real that's kind of repeating
myself there's a kind of like calm
Menace behind his voice that I I
actually was like nah I wasn't like oh
though I'm just listening to Tyrone talk
like no I'm buying what he's going for
here and what are you doing I would like
to see more cuz this this leaves me
wondering just what that character is
gonna be like like for the plot of the
show this gives me a sense for who he is
you know when shits about to go down but
I now I want to see you know who Derek
Chambers is you know on a regular day
yeah I want to see more of the world now
that I will say this teaser trailer has
done a good job on making me intrigued
into wanting to know more about the
actual world of where vengeance takes
place yeah yeah yeah cause it's like III
like you know these are all the cool
kind of shots again that I you don't
want to see out of something like this
like it definitely hooks me with like
that ooh like seems like they're really
gonna get into some you know ass-kicking
and yeah you know gritty crime stuff and
also you know cops and robbers element I
want to know what the plot of the series
is gonna be like yeah I want to know
what the character driven plots will be
a bit like who is this girl that's
punching his hands and he's training
right here and she picks up a shotgun at
one point it's like so obviously the
riders know their story I'm sure there's
a full script already rate he goes
doesn't have a pilot or whatever and
that's what's engrossing to me too it's
like is seeing you know what Tyrone is
like um in a fictional setting when the
scene plays out yeah yeah I mean real
life is just a pervert yeah [ __ ] yes
actually Ryan Wright was based on Tyrone
it yeah all right Tyrone thanks for
letting us watch that trailer I'm glad
this went up exclusively on your channel
because you wrote and directed this
whole thing no credit goes to Michael
Mateo Rossi all you I will give you
credit I might mm I know you know Mike
Mike is probably watching this video at
some point Mike just step out a
spotlight but I want to take credit for
everything I'm only gonna call you baby
want me to get a show done listen my
girl
just hand over all the credentials to
Tyra I mean you know I think you can
just keep some parts that you did and he
can keep his parts but I'm trying to
tell you about marketing listen to this
guy
Michael Matteo Rossi I think you're like
the third Russo brother for some reason
that's not bad
I wouldn't be bad at all I would go with
that yeah I know there's a cool trailer
a shot well Tyrone had his monologue
delivered well I wasn't laughing when he
was talking I was actually like buying
what he was saying so everything that
comes across in the Caesar totally works
and it makes me intrigued to want to see
more and if this gets picked up if you
actually have a show I will not be
jealous at all subscribe to the real
rejects Daris even one person George oh
come it's okay you too stupid I hate you
- you love YouTube don't say hey youtube
you love YouTube hey Tyrone I hate
Hakkasan a new cater bar and I hate his
other friend Gator Martin has that other
bro the sup Rosa think his name's Cooley
I hate Dante I hate all them but do you
hate Shay a PewDiePie I love Jake
alright